[Music]
that's why I'm here I think you know way
to break you're close to free you from
the Dutchman I'd rather our treasure a
treasure that holds all the power of the
seeds to try to decide and can break
your clothes
[Music]
and I
to try to connect yourself found you
[Music]
like the tales of um Captain Jack
Sparrow he will help you find a choice
you stay away from Jack leave the sea
forever just stop acting my pirate
don't stop
I'm going to come home
oh just a little yoga spot Oh Spanish
there are label slip-on green another
dureena it was so painful but you defend
me there's nothing bother really
right now I have no time to chat because
we max just ran away and we'll be
waiting for you why would you be waiting
for me what is he waiting for me I'm
looking for Mike Jax Tara I'm inspector
Hemme is sold either have a supercilious
Olympus
I'm currently what's the treating so not
with only good climbing I'm looking for
a Pirate Captain Jack Sparrow
it's days already nice cuz I just
happened to be Captain Jack no I can't
I've spent years searching for this the
great Jack Sparrow is not some drunk
inner self through Eve another ship a
crew pants a great pirate does not
require such intricacy do you know how
long I've been waiting for this moment
the risks I've taken to be here you sure
your VX stone how would you like the guy
pirate hey Larry
your invention the guillotine guillotine
sound French
I love the French did you know that they
invented mayonnaise our Becca BB it's
French hey
oh ah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here's an idea for one with her good
old-fashioned spelling I I killed mr.
not there get the crowd involved doesn't
it
I should like to speak the vicar
municipality to me probably power I'm
not one complain normally this baskets
for a head
you